antes de profundizar en la afinidad de
electrónica veamos un repaso de la
energía de ionización empecemos con un
átomo neutro de litio que tiene una
configuración electrónica 1 s 2 2s 1
entonces como un átomo de litio tiene 3
protones en el núcleo escribimos una
carga 3 positiva y después tenemos 2
electrones en el orbital 1 s estos son
nuestros dos electrones en el orbital 1
s o también se les conoce como
electrones centrales y tenemos un
electrón en el orbital 2 s este es el
electrón más externo es nuestro electrón
de valencia y el electrón de valencia
está alejado de la carga 3 positiva del
núcleo por la presencia de los
electrones centrales y como las cargas
iguales se repelen los electrones
centrales repelen al electrón externo
alejándolo de la carga 3 positiva pero
aún tenemos una fuerza de atracción
entre el núcleo cargado positivamente y
el
este electrón externo porque cargas
opuestas se atrae el electrón externo
aún siente un poco de atracción por el
núcleo por lo tanto como el electrón es
atraído al núcleo se necesita energía
para quitar este electrón de valencia
del átomo neutro entonces si quitamos el
electrón externo es decir el electrón de
valencia nos quedamos con el ión de
litio que tiene una carga positiva es
una carga 1 positiva porque aún tenemos
3 protones pero ahora sólo tenemos 2
electrones por eso en total tenemos una
carga 1 positiva y como para esta
ionización se necesita energía para
quitar el electrón la energía de
ionización es positiva y se mide en
kilovolts por mol entonces comparemos
eso con la afinidad electrónica
vamos a ver en la afinidad electrónica
digamos que empezamos nuevamente con el
átomo de litio neutro pero esta vez en
lugar de quitarle un electrón le
agregamos un electrón
agregamos un electrón al orbital 2s
entonces empezamos con 3 electrones en
el átomo neutro de litio y ahora
agregamos uno más por lo que la
configuración electrónica del ión de
litio sería 1 s 2 2s 2 aún tenemos 3
cargas positivas en el núcleo 12
electrones en el orbital 1s pero ahora
hemos agregado un electrón así que en
total tenemos 4 electrones porque
tenemos 2 electrones en el orbital 2s
vamos a resaltar el electrón que
agregamos de color rosa
este es el electrón que agregamos al
átomo de litio neutro y sabemos que este
electrón es alejado de la carga 3
positiva del núcleo por los electrones
centrales que tenemos aquí porque las
cargas opuestas se repelen pero también
es un poco repelido por este electrón
que también está en el orbital 2s
entonces este electrón también repele
pero aún existe una fuerza de atracción
entre el núcleo cargado positivamente y
la carga negativa del electrón así que
al agregar el cuarto electrón se libera
energía y cómo se libera energía la
afinidad electrónica tiene un valor
negativo y al agregar un electrón al
átomo de litio neutro tenemos menos 60
kilos jules por mol entonces se libera
energía cuando se agrega un electrón y
eso es porque el electrón que agregamos
es atraído por el núcleo entonces si el
núcleo siente una fuerza de atracción
por el electrón agregado obtendremos un
valor negativo de afinidad electrónica
esa es una forma de medir la afinidad
electrónica y observen que el avión de
litio es un poco más grande que el avión
de litio neutro aunque es un poco
difícil demostrarlo con estos diagramas
entonces mientras el electrón agregado
sienta una fuerza de atracción por el
núcleo se libera energía hagamos otra
comparación entre la energía de
ionización y la
de electrónica vamos a ver en la energía
de ionización como el electrón externo
es atraído al núcleo nos cuesta trabajo
quitar ese electrón entonces como se
necesita energía para quitar ese
electrón necesitamos aplicar un trabajo
así que la energía es positiva en
términos de energía de ionización pero
en términos de afinidad electrónica como
el electrón que agregamos es atraído a
la carga positiva del núcleo no tenemos
que forzar esto no tenemos que hacer
ningún trabajo porque se libera energía
en este proceso y es por eso que la
afinidad electrónica tiene un valor
negativo las afinidades electrónicas no
tienen que ser negativas existen casos
en los que para algunos átomos no hay
atracción por un electrón extra por
ejemplo veamos el neón la configuración
electrónica del neón es 1 s 2 2s 2
36 así que tenemos dos más 26 tenemos un
total de 10 electrones y una carga 10
positiva en el núcleo para un átomo de
neón neutro entonces digamos que este es
nuestro núcleo con una carga y es
positiva tenemos 10 protones y después
tenemos 10 electrones alrededor de ese
núcleo
este es nuestro átomo de neón neutro y
si tratamos de agregar un electrón aún
tenemos 10 protones en el núcleo aún
tenemos los 10 electrones que ahora son
los electrones centrales y al agregar un
electrón este es el año de neón entonces
tenemos 1 s 2 2s 2 236 el segundo nivel
de energía está lleno así que al agregar
un electrón necesitamos otro nivel de
energía entonces pasamos al tercer nivel
de energía y nos encontramos en el
orbital s en el que tenemos un electrón
entonces supongamos que es
es el electrón que agregamos queremos
agregar un electrón al átomo de neón
pero si pensamos en la carga nuclear
efectiva que siente este electrón de
color rosa la carga nuclear efectiva es
igual al número atómico o número de
protones - el número de electrones
centrales y como tenemos 10 protones en
nuestro núcleo esto sería 10 y los
electrones centrales también son 10
entonces esos 10 electrones alejan al
electrón que agregamos de la carga 10
positiva del núcleo y para un cálculo
rápido esto nos dice que la carga
nuclear efectiva es igual a 0 claro
estamos simplificando mucho las cosas
pero podemos pensar que el electrón
externo que estamos tratando de agregar
no siente ninguna atracción por el
núcleo porque estos 10 electrones lo
alejan completamente de la carga 10
positiva y como no hay atracción por
este electrón no se libera energía en
este proceso más
se necesita energía para forzar que el
electrón se quede en el átomo de neón
entonces se necesita energía para forzar
que un electrón sea agregado a un átomo
de neón neutro y como el neón no siente
afinidad por un electrón extra es por
eso que no reacciona es un gas noble y
esta es una forma de explicar por qué
los gases nobles no reaccionan porque el
lyon que tratamos de obtener no durará
mucho y se necesita energía para forzar
todo esto así que podríamos decir que la
afinidad electrónica es positiva se
necesita energía pero generalmente no
encontramos valores positivos para la
afinidad electrónica al menos en los
libros que he consultado así que podemos
decir que la afinidad electrónica del
neón es cero porque es muy difícil
calcular el valor real
aquí tenemos a los elementos del segundo
periodo de la tabla periódica analicemos
sus afinidades electrónicas ya vimos que
al agregar un electrón a un átomo de
litio neutro se liberan 60 kilos urss
formol después tenemos el berilio con
una afinidad electrónica de 0 eso
significa que más bien necesita energía
porque este es un número positivo
entonces se necesita aplicar energía
para agregar un electrón a un átomo
neutro de berilio miren si tenemos un
átomo neutro de berilio y queremos
formar el avión de berilio si analizamos
las configuraciones electrónicas la
configuración del átomo de berilio
neutro es 1 s 2 2s 2 entonces para
formar el avión de berilio cargado
negativamente tenemos 1 s 2 2s 2 pero al
agregar el electrón extra tenemos que
pasar al orbital 2 p que es de mayor
energía así que esto es lo mismo o al
menos muy parecido a lo que vimos con el
neón
en el neón la configuración electrónica
es 1 s 2 2 s 226 y al agregar un
electrón extra necesitamos pasar al
tercer nivel de energía abrimos una
nueva capa electrónica y el electrón que
agregamos es alejado completamente de la
carga positiva del núcleo por los otros
electrones y algo muy parecido ocurre
con el avión de berilio al agregar ese
electrón extra necesitamos abrir un
nivel más alto de energía con lo que
este electrón se encuentra muy alejado
del núcleo porque estos electrones lo
alejan de la carga positiva del núcleo y
por lo tanto no hay afinidad por este
electrón agregado entonces se necesita
energía para formar el avión de berilio
por eso aquí tenemos cero el berilio no
tiene afinidad de electrónica ahora
analicemos el bor aquí se liberan 27
kilos jules por mol y ya empezamos a ver
una tendencia porque cuando pasamos del
boro al carbono y después al oxígeno
y al flúor conforme nos movemos a lo
largo de este periodo de la tabla
periódica podemos ver que se libera más
energía por lo tanto el flúor tiene más
afinidad por los electrones conforme nos
movemos a lo largo del periodo aumenta
la afinidad de electrónica entonces el
signo negativo significa que se libera
energía y podemos ver que se libera más
energía cuando agregamos un electrón a
un átomo de flúor neutro y después si
agregamos un electrón a un átomo de
oxígeno neutro y bueno podemos explicar
esta tendencia con la carga nuclear
efectiva porque conforme avanzamos a lo
largo del periodo también incrementa la
carga nuclear efectiva y si el electrón
agregado siente más atracción por el
núcleo que es lo que queremos decir aquí
al incrementar la carga nuclear efectiva
más energía será liberada al agregar ese
electrón entonces esta idea general
explica la tendencia general que podemos
observar en la afinidad
electrónica conforme avanzamos a lo
largo del periodo de la tabla periódica
aumenta la afinidad de electrónica y ya
dijimos que el berilio es una excepción
al igual que el neón pero que me dicen
del nitrógeno bueno podemos ver que el
nitrógeno no siente afinidad por el
electrón y tal vez se encuentren con
diferentes valores dependiendo del libro
que consulten pero si analizamos
rápidamente las configuraciones
electrónicas podemos tratar de explicar
eso miren la configuración electrónica
del nitrógeno es 1 s 2 2s 2 y después 2
p 3
entonces si dibujamos los orbitales
supongamos que este es el orbital 2s y
estos son los orbitales 2 p entonces
pongamos los electrones
vamos a ver tenemos 2 electrones en el
orbital s y después tenemos 3 electrones
en los orbitales p ok y si queremos
agregar un electrón a un nitrógeno
neutro agregamos un electrón
uno de estos orbitales que ya tienen un
electrón al agregar un electrón a uno de
esos orbitales el electrón agregado es
repelido por el electrón que ya teníamos
inicialmente esa es la razón por la que
este átomo no sigue la tendencia el
nitrógeno no siente afinidad electrónica
por un electrón extra y bueno después de
todo esto es obvio que la afinidad
electrónica es un poco más complicada
que la energía de ionización la energía
de ionización es una tendencia más fácil
de explicar mientras que con la afinidad
electrónica conforme nos movemos a lo
largo del periodo en la tabla periódica
podemos ver una tendencia pero hay
muchas excepciones y tal vez nuestra
explicación es muy simple para explicar
lo que realmente ocurre pero bueno a lo
largo del periodo podemos ver una
especie de tendencia porque al movernos
a lo largo de los grupos encontramos más
inconsistencias y no vale la pena tratar
de establecer una tendencia generalizada
para